alright i'm going to introduce our first
speaker and his name is dr. Frank curse
Caruso he is a professor of Plant
Pathology at the University of
Massachusetts cranberry station and east
wareham Massachusetts he has research
goals in a wide variety of cranberry
disease systems and we are very pleased
to have him today to talk to us and dr.
Caruso I hope that you are there and
are ready to begin
are we having some audio problems Frank
it remember that little there we go got
me
I think I can hear gotcha you're there
okay so i can get started yes you can
it's cutting out all right but it's
cutting out I don't hear anything in my
your father Frank we can hear you
beautifully ok now it appears
so I don't have to hear any background
stuff I can just go ahead should
actually be quiet in the back okay I do
I do
okay where's my presentation
no I have the welcome okay it's loading
I hope this takes longer I mean I hope
it doesn't take as long as it did the
other day okay this seems to be going
better I'm at fifty percent now I don't
usually get nervous for talks like this
anymore but there's so much stuff that
can happen for this not to happen in its
full fruition I just hope I have a
better day today than Bill Belichick had
on Sunday night I'm waiting for the
presentation to pop up in front of me
here
and then I can get started when I see it
huh that's weird still don't see it
computer but okay
alright Frank you want may want to check
your toggle button and make sure that
that's that little thing stays on
because apparently we're getting a
little bit of cutting out yep
yeah I remember this was happening on a
meek the other day when we did our
practice okay I have the talk in front
of me now okay yeah okay Tom well well
you have your time on sunday with us
don't you all right I did not see any
cranberry growers but even if you grow
something else never assume that you're
not going to grow cranberries so listen
intently here I'm going to talk today
about cranberry diseases particularly
the east coast version and of all of our
disease is the most important one that
we have to deal with is fruit rot now
fruit rot consists of two things field
rot before the berries are harvested and
storage rot after the berries going to
storage which doesn't impact you unless
you are a fresh fruit grower which for
us in Massachusetts is about ten percent
of our harvested material and I remember
this had issues advancing the other day
in a timely fashion so we have to be
patient this is a big file and hmm it's
going to be hard to get through my talk
in 30 minutes if this is what it's going
to take to advance each one of these
slides oh come on Frank hopefully it
might be getting better as it
it gets warmed up here and hopefully
it'll improve yeah of course I've pushed
the button four times which means it's
probably going to jump ahead to the
fourth slide when it finally comes on so
this is very frustrating field rot is an
issue every year for cranberry growers
and it's a he okay you guys are getting
it before I am and it sounds like it's
it's advancing to probably ahead of
where it supposed to barely ride but I
still have yeah well see this is this is
strange because I'm still on the first
slide the fruit rots lon you guys are
ahead of me and it's hard to me doc
until I have the slide in front of me
here all right early right well now I
got to back up but maybe I'll say the
heck with backing up because it's going
to take forever I just backed up one so
then we have to wait for me to go back
one so I'm never going to back up and
I'm never going to push this arrow more
than once i'm just going to have to be
very patient okay well at any rate i had
a couple slides that you're not going to
see but at any rate the fruit rot that
you get in the field that goes to the
handler does not include the berries
that you can see right here which is the
are the ones that are left behind on the
bog that we see as trash these are very
small and they never make it onto the
truck these are all fruit rot however
although there may be some fruit worm
mixed in there some of our rots can be
readily identifiable by symptoms this
one that you can see here is the one we
call early rot and typically what you'll
see for this one is concentric circles
on the berry this is our first rot that
shows up in the field this is caused by
the fungus file of stick to these are
all fungal induced
fruit rots and rot you can see the
symptoms on the calyx end of the the
berry here I'm even having issues with
the pointer here but there's the pointer
you can see the rot that's developing
there on the calyx and this is caused by
the fungus fuser kakim these berries on
the right here these are ones caused by
right brought colio foaming I'm also
having issues with the pointer which
doesn't seem to be working here either
healthy berries on the left Kolia Felmy
is the causal agent here and now I have
to wait for the next Sode can i just
enter here right well again I have to be
very patient I'm sorry for interrupting
but there we go here's yeah okay if you
want to I are listening a host and you
can then we can watch your cursor but
you just have to promise that you won't
push any buttons that change everything
on me and that way we can watch your
cursor if you would like
I don't do that I'll just click change
your status okay
and now we should be able to watch your
cursor
okay well this one you see
this one you see is black rot which
turns the berries totally jet black and
the causal agent of this one is atlanta
from opsys again nothing is coming up in
a very timely fashion here so again
patience is a virtue I should have
printed out these things so I knew what
was coming ahead of time yeah I know you
guys all seem to be getting these before
I do here which is very frustrating i'm
still looking at black rod here and i
know we had issues with this okay now i
haven't this is miscellaneous rot which
means these are berries that you can't
readily identify by a particular fungus
these ones here so in order to isolate
and determine what the causal agent is
these berries have to be in my hand so
that I can culture out fungi again
waiting for godot here I'm still looking
at miscellaneous rot
there's obviously many issues that have
to be dealt with here apologize prank in
the future to make these things run
smoothly because this is not I'm still
looking at before well this is fall this
is followed me my whole life creation of
new problems at any rate just because
you have berries that look like here
this is not a fruit rot situation these
are barriers that were scalded by very
quick heat temperature changes these are
rotted berries on the left here and you
can tell they're rotted berries because
you can see all the anthocyanin essence
around the area of rot so this is how
you can tell that you have fruit rot
because those scalded berries will
eventually look like this and if I don't
see them in the field right after
they've been schooled that I can't tell
the difference between rot and scald we
have cultured as many as nine different
fungi out of one rotted berry and in
some instances you'll have a berry like
this one here that has absolutely no rod
on it at all the one on the right we
have a real disease complex for fruit
rot as you can see there are 12 listed
organisms here the ones that have two
asterisks affixed to them are the ones
that are the most important for us in
Massachusetts in pretty much in New
Jersey as well if you go to the Midwest
and Wisconsin and then Pacific Northwest
in Oregon Washington and British
Columbia they're very different
situations out there the fungus final
stick that can also cause a disease
symptom we call blossom blast you can
actually see some of the fruiting bodies
of the pathogen right here and right
here as well fruit rot management
includes a true integrated approach of
many things from the application of
fungus
sides to the using of floodwaters
keeping good air circulation by pruning
the vines or sanding the vines removal
of trash after the flood irrigating them
properly and using cultivars that are
less susceptible to fruit rot this is a
list of our fungicides that were
registered in this past growing season
you can see we have a wide range of
active ingredients that we can choose
from the best one of these by far is the
chlorothalonil group Bravo clora nil
echo Equus although some of these other
ones are very good as well our
fungicides go on when the cranberry
blossoms go into bloom usually our first
application going on at ten percent
bloom followed in Massachusetts by two
subsequent applications they will use
one or two more in New Jersey because
they have a bigger issue of fruit rot in
New Jersey in a conventional situation
which is one where they don't use a
spring reef Luud that I'll be talking
about shortly again the fungicides go on
early during bloom to apply those
fungicides you must use the phenological
plant development don't go by just
because you applied your first
application June fifteenth last year
that you should do the same this year
some years were two weeks ahead some
years were two weeks behind we have
mostly protectant fungicides but now we
have some new materials that do have
kickback activity or systemic activity
endure and abound you need to determine
whether your fate of your fruit are
going to be processed or for fresh fruit
your cultivars will determine what you
do Stephens being the most resistant
Bentley or being the most susceptible
you should never use any fungicide this
goes for you blueberry growers dealing
with blueberry diseases you should never
use a fungicide at less the registered
rate there's a good reason why that high
rate and low rate are there because
we've done the testing ahead
if you have a material like a Bravo that
has very good sticking agents you should
not add something to it to add
presumably better sticking ability
because you'll end up with phytotoxicity
for us late water is a particular
management of water that we use by
flooding from mid-april until mid-may by
using this you can reduce your number of
applications to as few as one
applications during the current growing
season in subsequent years as well you
can use later applications and the
tricky thing is when you use late water
is that bloom will be compressed into a
shorter time period and your plants will
be very susceptible to frost coming out
of that flood trash piles you'll see
bogside and these trash piles are
tremendous source of inoculum as you can
see the fruiting bodies on this one leaf
and the fruiting bodies on this one
bearing that are sitting right in that
trash pile these are pathogenic fungi
that are overwintering here as far as
the irrigation goes you should never
water at night going into the long
evening where the water film will sit on
the plants for 12 to 14 hours water in
the early morning this goes if you have
any kind of plants you should irrigate
in the early morning to minimize the
optimal conditions for infection we do
have some cultivars that do have some
field rot resistance as you can see here
we also have ones that have good storage
rot resistance we have some new
cultivars available to growers coming
out of the Rutgers breeding program in
the Wisconsin breeding program and we're
still trying to assess the
susceptibility and resistance of these
particular cultivars to fruit rot we're
getting a pretty good idea so far what
their situation is now some of these
fruit rot pathogens can also cause leaf
spot in newly planted beds this seems to
be an increasing problem and you can see
the the fungus that's probably the most
important is the one at the top their
file is dicta although colletotrichum
seems to be a big problem issue causing
organism as well here is a situation
where we have a leaf spot and you can
see the fruiting bodies on this
particular leaf right there these are
symptoms of the fungus file of stick to
again you can see the fruiting bodies on
the leaves and how it can significantly
d Foley ate the plants if the infection
is severe in fact with this fungus we're
now even seeing stem canker on some of
the stems because some of our new
cultivars are particularly susceptible
to file a stick to all right leaving
fruit rot behind and what I'd like to do
is is leave questions to the end so i
can keep moving here our next disease of
importance for us is Phytophthora root
rot it's the same photographer that
affects blueberries this is what it does
in a cranberry bed and you can see how
much death of the vines are occurring
you can also see how poor the drainage
is in this particular area here's an
aerial shot showing you the significant
areas of this disease that can occur in
a particular bed it's nothing to scoff
at using my pointer i will show you
where the new areas of the disease are
occurring get it early is the key again
you can see the areas of poor drainage
and the areas of died back in this
particular bog these are some
artificially inoculated plants that we
did years and years ago here's a healthy
plant and here's a fight otha infected
plant you can see what it does to the
root systems and that's why the the top
of the plants turn red and will
eventually die
here's healthy roots you can see they're
typically yellow here's phytophthora
infected plants which are typically an
olivaceous color very readily
identifiable if you take these roots
here and you put them on culture media
within 48 to 72 hours we have the fungus
fight after cinema me we can do a very
quick diagnosis we can do this with
blueberries as well we did some earlier
this summer this is the sporangium
filled with sporangia spores that will
spread the fungus around it can readily
spread in water these are the causal
agents phytother cinema me is the most
important one but we will find these two
other species of phytophthora present
management fight Toffler root rot is
again a truly integrated disease you can
see a lot of things need to be done the
low spots need to be improved drainage
wise you can assist this by sending
those areas fertilizing the peripheral
plants using some resistant cultivars
fungicides are very important in
preventing the spread of these this is
the one that you need to do first and
foremost and in many cases if you do
this one you don't need to do any of the
rest here are some means of improving
the drainage you can see the area fight
after there and how they improve the
drainage digging the ditches out
maintaining good drainage is another
important means of controlling this
disease sanding applying sin to the
affected area as you can see here what's
nice when these things advance on a
timely fashion these are peripheral
plants that were originally read and
with careful fertilizing they have
greened up nicely and are now moving
back into the area of dead vines riddim
ill and Ally yet are our two most
utilized fungicides are the same ones
that you can use for blueberry
phytophthora upright die back boy it
really helps if you get into a nice
rhythm here I'm just clicking now
upright dieback is a disease that we
will see every year in Massachusetts
they also see in New Jersey in Wisconsin
in the Pacific Northwest this is
typically what you will see and we will
see some infections that will affect
twenty-five to thirty percent of the
uprights depending on the individual bed
you may have only vegetative uprights
affected on a 500 to one basis versus
the fruiting uprights or you may see a
one to one situation where fruiting
uprights are getting clobbered just as
badly as the vegetative ones are here's
your symptom right here going from the
tip downward on this one you can see
every single one of your uprights are
affected these are the causal agents of
upright die back we've proven film opsys
we've proven Synchron oblasti ax we've
proven fiuza kakim we think collet
oricum is also involved but from opsys
no question this is the most important
fungus management of upright dieback
includes several things avoiding stress
on the plants managing fruit rot because
those organisms that were listed there
not only can they cause upright die back
they can also cause fruit fraught so
they're molter multifaceted pathogens in
Massachusetts in New Jersey we're
allowed to use a pre bloom application
of Bravo or champ Bravo is the better
one and as any diseases avoid excessive
vine growth because this allows for
perfect conditions for fungal infection
to occur here's the stage that you need
to have of your vines when you apply the
fungicide for upright dieback management
fairy ring is a disease that we have in
Massachusetts in New Jersey only it's an
East Coast disease here's your typical
rings right here in fact this bog has
rings all over the place it's Stevens
which is the most susceptible cultivar
here's a close-up of another ring that
you can see right here
rings are typically found right on the
ditches now we may actually change the
name of this disease to another disease
based on the finding that we we have a
very unique pathogen this one here we
may end up calling the disease violet
root rot instead and we are still
working out all the details on the life
cycle of this thing it's very
complicated life cycle where it consists
of a haploid Michael parasitic stage and
the Dyke re otic phyto parasitic stage
this is the one you need to control
right here on cranberries the phyto
parasitic stage it involves a lot of
different organisms structures that the
the fungus will produce management of
this we're still working out the details
on this but again avoiding stress
applying a bound in Dar or ferb am but
firm am comes later you can't apply for
bail until after june first you can use
these after May first and watering these
things these indoor and abound
applications in before and after
application seem to work the best now we
have some minor diseases that we really
don't have to deal with in so I listed
them here and I'm going to show you some
pictures to show you what they look like
and that will essentially wrap up the
presentation here so let's look at some
typical symptoms of these this is protiv
ensuring a leaf spot we see this one
every year in Massachusetts you're
typically diagnostic symptoms on the
upper surface of the leaves this is
parental batteries leaf spot another
leaf spotting fungus very similar to
protiv and sharia this is rose bloom
which is one of the three XO Bosinney
emboss diseases that we have in the East
Coast we've only seen this on the in tuk
at Island so far this is more of a West
Coast disease but this is the typical
flowery type of overgrowth that you have
on the second year but
this is red leaf spot caused by another
species of X obesity and we had quite a
lot of this this year because the
weather was so wet and so cool and this
is red shoot disease a typical shoot
infected by this particular species of X
obesity and three different species of X
omis iniyum involved no it is not the
same fungus that causes fairy ring and
turf this is cotton ball disease you can
see the mycelium on the inside of these
berries I've seen cotton ball in one
berry in Massachusetts in 25 growing
seasons so the fungus and the disease
are here but it's not an issue for us
like it is in Wisconsin and in
Washington and Oregon Wisconsin this is
their number one disease problem that
they usually have to deal with the
fungus is very closely related to the
mummy berry fungus in blueberry it has a
shoot blight phase that you can see here
so the fungus will spoil eight on this
material producing conidia and those
conidia infect the blossoms and result
in those berries that show the typical
cotton ball symptoms and the berries boy
I wish these were advancing like this
early on and I hadn't lost my patience
so much this is frost blossom disease
which is caused by a phytoplasma which
is vectored by the blunt nosed
leafhopper it's a disease that was
rampant in the industry back in the 20s
and the 30s and consequently almost
destroyed the industry in New Jersey it
was managed particularly well by
eliminating the blunt nosed leafhopper
but the fact of the matter is is this
this disease is still present in wild
cranberry beds in both Massachusetts in
New Jersey and so it has not gone away
it is still around and you can see what
it does to the blossoms no fruit
produced this is one of our virus
diseases are few virus diseases this is
ringspot red ringed spot probably the
same as we have in blueberries symptoms
on the
it does not impact the yield from
everything that we've been able to see
these are the symptoms on the leaves
this is funky flower condition that we
again just have on the East Coast you
can see the symptom here we have an
a-type and a b-type and this is the
typical symptom of the a type in
Massachusetts here we can see normal
blossoms here funky a funky B and this
is false blossom so we do have some
virus conditions to deal with these are
caused by virus very similar to cucumber
mosaic virus stem canker gall is
something that we will see in
Massachusetts some years it is caused by
the very closely related bacterium to
what causes crown gall and we hardly
ever do see it and its associated
supposedly with winter injury this
symptom here is very typical it looks
like upright died back in the field and
this seems to be more of a problem in
Wisconsin then it is in the East Coast I
must mention parasitic nematodes because
we do sometimes have very high levels of
this one in particular Hemi sickly offer
the sheaf now nematode we don't have
anybody doing work on nematodes in
cranberries except for some spotty work
on the west coast at Oregon State and in
British Columbia they may be more of a
problem than we realize they are and may
impact yields in certain situations we
have some valuable sources of
information that you can learn more this
is our cranberry chart book that we put
out of UMass here every year we renew it
we are currently working on the second
edition of the compendium of blueberry
cranberry and lingonberry diseases and
we'll have it available to you sometime
next year it is going currently going
through the editorial process we also
have this book that talks about
cranberry production as it is in
Massachusetts but cranberry production
here is the same as it is anywhere they
grow cranberries in
many ways and now I have time for
questions any questions does anybody
have any questions for Frank that was a
great job we got through that
beautifully and certainly cranberries
are really fascinating I had the good
fortune to go on a tour this summer of a
cranberry bog and it was just really
really interesting I think we might have
a question coming
well I was could was kind of like Tom
Brady the beginning of the season he
couldn't hit Randy mawson once he got a
good rhythm he started hitting him time
and time again they're out of the
question for cranberry growers
Tom organic cranberry production in the
East in Massachusetts in New Jersey is
about as challenging as you can find
anywhere we do have people doing it we
do have people that are doing it
successfully but it's a constant battle
especially with insects and weeds and
with fruit rod so I won't say that you
can't do it but it has about every
challenge you can expect in the world
thrown at you all right do we have any
additional comments before we move to
our next presenter
yeah believe me this lots of discussion
on that one in New England this week
very very much for that I'm sorry we got
off to a rocky start so I should turn my
mic off and I'm going I should turn my
mic off now animate shoulder and change
the presentations here
dr. shoulder I should have asked you I
just turned on the shortened version and
perhaps that it's not the one you wanted
and I you had two versions the shortened
and the regular one anime
hi I think we could the shortened
version um Laura that is the 1i just cut
it back a little bit because of the time
constraints you suitin yes dr. Anna
makes shoulder is a professor of Plant
Pathology with Michigan State University
in east lansing michigan where she works
to develop environmentally and
economically sustainable methods of
disease control in small fruit crops and
today she's going to be talking about to
us specifically about blueberry virus
and anna make you can go ahead it looks
like some people might think you're a
little bit loud so i don't know if we
should change here okay can you adjust
to where it's comfortable i think i
think i would go ahead with the volume
picture there at and hopefully they can
adjust their own on their headsets or
their own audio levels on their computer
that sounds great well I put myself to
medium volume now and I hope it's not
too loud then perfect ok so I'll get
started ok well thank you so much Laura
and Frank thanks for being the guinea
pig on this one I hope mine
to noon everyone do if you have any
comments yeah try to put them in the
chat box so I can see I will try to
check that I did notice that my
presentation change a little bit of the
slides look well to me they might look
different from what I put together and
I'm not sure what that that is about but
I think everything is there so today I
will be talking about blueberry viruses
as you know they have been more of a
problem lately and the Michigan
situation has been in the in a news so
there has been an interesting summer and
what I want to do is to give you an
overview of the viruses that affect
blueberries some of these are mostly
prevalent in Michigan and not in many
other places but I thought that you
should be aware of the symptoms just in
case the symptoms show up so let's see
aha first question is what is a virus
virus is really quite different from
fungi and bacteria which is what you've
probably realized as people are talking
about the flu virus and how antibiotics
don't work against flu viruses so a
virus is really a very simple pathogen
it consists of DNA on RNA which is
genetic material surrounded by a
protective protein coat I'll try to get
the the arrow going here hmm the pointer
there we go so that's the protein coat
and this would be the genetic material
and they are dependent on their hosts
whether it's an animal or a plant for
their reproduction and the question
sometimes comes up is are they really
alive or or not but they are able to
reproduce and infect with the help of
their host plants virus is extremely
small they can only be viewed by an
electron microscope and if you look at
this this picture next here these are
virus part
calls these would be magnified a hundred
thousand times for you to see them and
their president plant SAP and as small
as they are it's interesting how much
damage they can cause so what happens
when a virus gets in it plants and so a
virus and I've drawn it as a little
vampire but in reality of course it's a
it's a boring little particle but if it
gets into the plant cell and what
happens is it takes off its protein coat
and it hijacks the cell the cell
machinery to make copies of itself so
the cell I will make copies of the virus
particle and of the protein coat it
reassembles and then it gets out from
that cell and starts to spread
throughout the plants so once it is in
the plant it has to redistribute to
every cell of that plant and that could
take a while from several months maybe
to a year but the virus can also end up
in the roots viruses do not have legs
even though that's what I drew but said
they don't have a way to spread except
for vegetative propagation which is one
of the main ways in which virus has
spread in plants and that's a big big
problem some viruses will spread through
seed as well as pollen some viruses need
a Fitz or other insects to spread them
basically the insect will suck up the
SAP of the plants virus particles are in
that and then it will spit it back out
into a healthy plants and even mites and
some nematodes are involved in the
spread of certain viruses in general
viruses have very specific relationships
with their vectors so it's not like any
insect can spread any virus it's it's a
quite specific situation
so viruses can be hard to control
because once the plant is infected it's
infected for life and there is no cure
they can be present in woody plants in a
symptomless state for several years
before you know that there's something
wrong with that plants and they can even
spread when the plants are symptomless
and it's further complicated by the fact
that some viruses remain symptomless in
certain plants but they still spread and
then when they get to a cultivar for
instance that's highly susceptible or
will show the symptoms then you get a
problem so they're pretty tricky in that
sense some important points about
viruses like I mentioned they most
commonly spread through vegetative
propagation so it's really important to
start with virus free planting material
and I think a lot of people either do
not notice or they feel well so
expensive maybe it's not worth it but I
think it's a very good investment
especially when you're working with a
crop that could live you know 30 to 50
years maybe longer each type of virus
has a specific vector or weighted in
which it moves from plant to plant and
so if there's insect vectors if you
control the vector you control the
spread of the virus unfortunately a
virus cannot be positively identified by
symptoms alone even though some viruses
are so characteristic that you know you
could say well that's probably that
virus to be absolutely sure you need to
do a laboratory analysis and a test that
is performed is akin to a pregnancy test
where you see a color reaction and then
you know the virus is present there also
some more advanced DNA based methods
some nursery cell virus tested nursery
stock and the way they do that is that
the mother blocks from which the
cuttings are taken our laboratory tested
for viruses every year that's also based
on visual inspection and then sorry
visual inspection and tissue culture
alone do not guarantee freedom from
viruses
because because some viruses are
symptomless okay so I'll go through the
most common virus symptoms in
blueberries the one that I think is most
striking and actually could be called
beautiful especially for plant
pathologists looking at those is
blueberry shoestring virus and this one
has really characteristic symptoms that
almost cannot be mistaken for anything
else but you will see the oak leaf
pattern so does reddening you can see
red blotches on the stems this is
usually what you see the first
and then there's the shoestring leaves
which are very thin strap like leaves so
if you see that that is very likely to
be blueberry shoestring virus this virus
in addition to being spread by
propagation material is spread by a fits
it tends to spread down the row because
a fits idle walk from planted plants has
more easier it's easier for them to work
down the road and to cross roads and
also because if there's mechanical
harvesting the mechanical harvesters
could pick up infective a fits and carry
them down a row transmissions usually
start in spring when aphids emerge and
can continue until fall leaf drop but
most of the spread will occur when a
thick populations explode so one of the
things that you could do to control
blueberry shoestring virus is to monitor
a fit populations and to use
insecticides well timed insecticides
including and washing harvesters after
harvesting and affected fields now when
I talk about control measures for
specific viruses I emphasize you know
additional control methods to virus free
or virus tested materials i think the
virus desert plant material goes for all
virus problems tomato ringspot virus is
actually a virus that infects a lot of
other hosts in addition to blueberry you
can tell that there's something wrong
and we find that this virus it's pretty
common in Michigan probably in other
areas to New York where you see leaf
spots sort of spotting in the plants
necrotic spots and the leaves are
distorted along those spots you can see
a decline adaiah back of plants usually
it's a one or a few plants in the area
that are showing this dye back and slow
decline tobacco ringspot virus is
another very similar virus and it also
looks quite similar it has the spotting
on the leaves and the leaves are
deformed or curled and in fact
Bush's will decline and eventually die
now here we have a little problem with
the formatting of the slide but
hopefully you can still read it both of
these viruses have a White House range
which includes many weeds dandelion
chick weeds and they can be carried from
you know from crop to crop by these
weeds also they infect tree fruits
apples etc so if you plant it after an
orchard you might have a problem with
this virus because it's transmitted by
dagger nematodes zifa nema américain IAM
and this nematode which is a small round
worm that lives in the soil and feeds on
plant roots can transmit the virus and
even for a year after the crop has been
removed so this is a bit of a problem so
if you do have this virus and again I
would recommend testing our diagnosis
first to be sure that's what's going on
if you do remove infected bushes you
should test the soil for the presence of
the dagger nematodes and if they are
present there's a good chance that they
will then transmit the virus to the next
planting or if you replant in those same
areas so fumigation with the fumigants
or rotating out of blueberries for
several years planting for instance
right as will not have the dynamical
survive beyond the you know that year
would be ways to control that and
maintaining good weed control there are
some resistance or tolerant cultivars
that can be planted and blueberry leaf
model virus is another virus that as far
as we know only is found in Michigan so
i'll talk about it briefly but just in
case people start seeing these symptoms
typically you see yellowing or modeling
modeling in sort of a light and dark
green areas on leaves stunting can occur
the leaves are very small and row
said it and more more less pointy and
this virus disease does cause some
problems it causes slow decline in
blueberries the variety rouble
especially declines more rapidly the
control of this disease sorry this
disease or this virus interestingly is
transmitted by pollen which are carried
by bees so you inadvertently gets
problems are the bees will be carrying
the pollen and the virus around and as I
mentioned is only non in Michigan so far
and the control would be to remove and
destroy infected bushes and not moving
beehives from infected fields this just
brings another aspect of certain virus
diseases where bees are involved in a
transmission of pollen
you place the hives and what you do with
the hives after pollination of the
blueberries okay another virus that is a
common are not very common but it occurs
in Michigan and it's also appears to
become more problematic in states like
North Carolina is blueberry red ringspot
virus and just looking at the symptoms I
think it's quite striking you could see
red blotches on the stems they sometimes
have a beautiful ring like shape but
most of the time it's more like a blotch
and then you see a red spotting on the
leaves that is only visible from the top
of the lease and it's the older leaves
that's started to have this problem
there may even be flex on the fruit and
delayed ripening and let's see I'm
having a little bit of a problem because
I don't see my screen anymore but this
thing is doing things without me
touching it so are we back no I don't
know what's going on okay I thought I
was doing something my fear was I was
doing something wrong okay well I'll
continue okay i hope this I'm not
running out of time or anything okay so
why the the formatting has changed to
hear but anyway blueberry what ringspot
virus does not reduce yield
significantly but today's ripening it
does not seem to spread in Michigan but
in New Jersey's it appears to be
transmitted by mealy bugs so in the rare
event that you start to see this you
know you would have to monitor infected
plants for spread and watch for mealy
bug and infected fields
okay blueberry mosaic this is something
that we don't actually know is caused by
a virus but we suspect it's a virus and
they have found virus-like particles in
these plants but it's still being
studied and so we don't know for sure
what virus we we have there but it's
pretty common I think in many growing
areas where you see this mosaic pattern
where there's yellow and green area
sometimes they're reddish sometimes the
Holies could be yellowish and so it's
not really very harmful we don't think
that there is a big deal it sometimes
looks like it's spreading but it could
be that in cool years you just have more
plan showing symptoms and the only known
source is infected plant material we
don't really recommend control but if
people were concerned you know the the
recipe would be the recommendation would
be to pull out that bush all right let
me see if its advancing so let's switch
to the viruses that have really made my
summer very very busy and are people I
know are concerned about these and you
should be because especially this
blueberry scourge virus is very
potentially damaging virus it's been
around in New Jersey for a long time and
it's called Sheep pen hill virus in that
area the characteristic symptoms are
sudden blighting of the flowers and
leaves during bloom so if you start to
see a lot of flowers all together
simultaneously blighting right before
they open that is potentially a problem
also the leaves and the young shoots
will will blight back this disease is
common in Oregon Washington and British
Columbia also new jersey it has been
found in Massachusetts Connecticut in
Europe in 2009 so this year we
in Michigan at several locations and
these locations or these fields were
destroyed to try and contain it because
since we don't know that this disease
exists anywhere else in Michigan and we
want to protect our industry we had to
go to this this process of destroying
the bushes in this case we could trace
the infection to a specific or two
nurseries that had plants that were
infected but those had been imported you
know 14 years ago from actually from New
Jersey and I'll show you later but they
were not showing typical symptoms so
that we didn't know they were infected
other symptoms of the blueberry scourge
virus are a yellowing or marginal leaf
necrosis as you can see here and
sometimes some cultivars show red line
patterns in the fall so if you see
patterns like these this is really quite
unusual and I would be concerned there
are multiple strains of the virus and
the symptoms of stray independence and
there is what they call an East Coast
rain and a West Coast reign and with the
West Coast rain there are some cultivars
which are symptomless so that is a bit
of a problem they can still serve as a
reservoir of the virus so if you planted
a symptom of cultivar you might start to
see symptoms in varieties that show
symptoms with that particular strain now
since then they've discovered that there
are many more strains that you know
really need to be studied because we
don't know all the reactions of these
strains the mild symptoms that could
easily be overlooked and also could be
confused with say nitrogen deficiency
are for instance in blue crop a pale
pale green leaves in blue crop at the
problem we had in Michigan was with a
variety legacy and the only symptom that
I could tell was a yellowing of the
leaves and sometimes some kind of
strange red leaf you know striped
patterns our line patterns on the leaves
so I think you know the growers just
thought the plants weren't growing very
well and and I just thought they did to
fertilize them more here you can see I
hope you can tell that the Scotch
infected legacy row and it was still a
very young planting and is much paler
than this row next to it and that's the
only indication that you would have had
that it was infected the only other way
was of course to do the laboratory
diagnosis and it came through that
almost one hundred percent of these
plans were infected with the virus
blueberry shock virus is very similar in
its symptoms you can see here that you
have also very simultaneous dieback of
shoots as well as blossoms same things
with scorch however it is a very
different virus and interestingly
there's a second flush of leaves that
occurs after these shock symptoms have
shown up you can see that there are some
live leaves on these on these canes and
that distinguishes it for instance from
form opsys however it is possible to
sometimes confuse the symptoms with the
mummy berry or with foam opsys this
virus is common in Oregon Washington and
British Columbia and unfortunately in
2009 we found one site that had this
disease it was at our research station
we still don't know where it came from
but it is possible that it came in with
some variety it was a variety tell trial
that was planted or some some breeding
lines we're not sure we are currently
trying to eradicate this virus now in
British Columbia Pacific Northwest they
find that the plants after several years
of showing symptoms will come back to
full production and that may be possible
in Michigan as well but we don't know
whether the virus would make the plans
let's winter hardy and therefore perhaps
more susceptible to winner injury but
over there they are not so concerned
about blueberry shark scorches the way
more
dangerous one and so they're just
suggesting to growers that they let the
disease run its course and but I don't
think we can do that because we don't
know what it would do in our region's
and you know if you still have it in a
small contained area the best approach
is to try and eradicate it so that it
doesn't spread and this disease can
spread very rapidly because it also
spreads via polym carried by bees here
you can see in infected plants and one
of the things I want to point out is
that distinguishes a virus disease from
other diseases is that you can see it
isn't this plant is showing a lot of
necrosis a lot of died back of the
shoots but the neighboring plants look
perfectly healthy so if you see this
very random pattern of a plant here and
there that has a sudden blighting off of
leaves I think that is what is very
indicative of a virus disease you might
see maybe two next to each other but
generally this if it is a fungal disease
you would see symptoms on other bushes
nearby and Laura that is a good sign I'm
almost done with my talk here so if you
suspect stroke or scourge i would say
suggest that you contact your local
extension agents you can mark the plans
and they'd leave samples from several
branches because the viruses may not be
distributed very well throughout the
plants and you can send them for
diagnosis either to a university
laboratory or to AG the air which is a
private lab or AC Diagnostics is another
private lab that will test samples and
the sample should be as fresh as
possible there's more information on the
on our blueberry websites plus the fact
sheets or pest alerts that I produced
are available through the webinar for
you to download and hopefully that will
help you recognize the symptoms I think
there's you know no need to panic I
think in many cases we have seen
just a very small area of infection that
could be traced back to certain you know
sources and I don't think we have any
widespread occurrence but we have to be
alert or vigilance so with that I do
have this table here that would just
show you or the different viruses and
their symptoms and their vectors and I
apologize for the the formatting change
that happened when I uploaded this and
also I didn't mention stunts because
that's not actually caused by a virus
but by a bacteria like agent but there's
more information on stunts in on the
website as well as in our virus fact
sheet and with that I'll stop and if
there's any time will entertain some
questions from oneida county can injury
from her besides give similar appearance
yeah I see could
I think it can and I think one of the
reasons why we did not recognize that we
had shocked at our research station is
because we had a lot of roundup and so
maybe some paraquat injury in our bushes
so the only difference would be that if
you have herbicide injury it tends to be
more widespread you know it wouldn't be
a single bush here or there and i think
that's that's probably the main way to
try to distinguish that chance i know
there has been a lot of interest and
frank has a question there oh it says
naman wonderful more information about
viruses at the new england vegetable and
varied conference in manchester new
hampshire and that day is on the
fifteenth 18th of december google that
you'll get right to their website for
registration info thank you Frank
oh and i would like to add to that that
for anyone attending the Great Lakes
expo in Michigan Bob Martin from Oregon
who is sort of the virus expert in
blueberries and other small fruits will
be attending and we'll be talking about
shokran scorch as well at that meeting
right that's a 8th to 10th dates to the
10th in Grand Rapids Michigan okay so
there's a question what if you don't
remove all of the roots would the virus
remain in the roots in the ground yes
there's a possibility that while the
roots remain alive that the virus
remains a life so it's very important to
if you had infected plants to kill them
apply an herbicide first before you pull
them out so that the roots are killed
let's see how this is going real fast
here is the Michigan certification
process working well for nursery plants
or is it possible that in fact the
plants have slipped through I think our
nursery certification process is working
however the the one scorched case
slipped through because there are
several reasons one is that it was
symptomless so it didn't initially give
any indication that there was something
wrong and we didn't know that we had
shocked or scourge in the state so we
didn't test for it until several years
ago and when we started testing for it
because we had also simultaneously at
Plum poxvirus the blueberry testing was
relegated to the the latter part of the
season in the fall and we didn't because
the virus concentration lower gets lower
the later you get into this season they
had some suspect samples but they
weren't sure that they were infected so
only this year did they confirm that it
really was infected so and those plans
were imported by the nursery 14 years
ago so they didn't sell any because they
weren't growing well but you know they
did slip through because you know we
just didn't test through variety of
circumstances but i think we you know
all the nursery plants are tested for
these both of these viruses now so we
should be it should be working okay
that's sorry how soon
yeah I can read them to you animate I'm
trying to catch up all the questions
here oh no I think let's see mmm how
soon as removing can you replant I think
you can replant if you're sure that the
roots are dead you can replant you know
within even several months but I think
it'd be good to plow up and if depending
on the virus if you have a nematode
borne virus you might have to wait
longer at least a year if it's one of
those viruses LexCorp tour shock you
have to make sure that the insects are
all killed if there's any em i'll call
it transmission by a Fitz and such and I
should mention it for the Scourge virus
we don't know that it's transmitted but
transmitted by the aphid that we have
which is Illinois a pepper I but it's
transmitted by Eric aphis species so
we're we're looking into that for the
fields in fact did you test for both
court and shocks him that since the
symptoms look alike yes we tested for
both because we didn't know which one
was which do you know if they plan to
record Bob Martin stock for later
viewing that's a good question I will
look into that for the Great Lakes expo
I don't think they have actually
recorded talks in the past they have
just put the presentation on online or
they have put some kind of summary
online I'll check into that to see if
that's possible and Frank's comment if
you have a positive detection of
squatchers shock at a New England state
I would like to know okay I think we
should all be you know I guess talking
to each other to know where these
viruses occur because I can guarantee
that once you start looking there will
be some places where it will show up I
think there was a lot of plant movements
before you know we were really aware of
these viruses
and some of it could have been just
moved there are moved years ago and is
infected maybe it hasn't spread
hopefully but once we start looking I
think we'll find more let's see our
realtor is required to test and certify
their stock as disease free no it's a
voluntary program and if you buy plants
you have to ask or be sure that it's
virus tested there are some nurseries
that have visual inspections and they
might say that you know it has been
inspected for diseases but that doesn't
mean it's virus tested it has to undergo
a laboratory test so you have to confirm
that with your nursery do you or Frank
have an opinion about USDA's National
clean plant Network very good question I
am right now at the barre Clinton
network meeting in st. Louis and we are
working on having I guess more virus
testing done and cleanup of planting
material and also perhaps support
certification programs for more
nurseries or states through this network
and I can you know it's still developing
so but they're working on it Cathy
growers with blueberry virus considering
or contact us a carrot Cox is there any
way we can find out nurseries carry the
infected point okay is there
um
and no right well I guess I'm not at
liberty to divulge which nursery that
was which carried the infected plans I
think they've worked on removing the
materials and contacting all the people
that might have purchased those plants
so I think that's the best I can do so
if you are contacted the one thing I can
mention is that for the scourge in our
area it was the variety legacy so if you
have any concerns about you have legacy
and not many people are growing it but
some people are using it for as a pollen
Iser for liberty some of the late
varieties if you're finding that it's
not growing well I would be uh you know
looking into that and have a tester
questions or comments things that they
like to share utter any other I want to
apologize these folks I don't know
exactly what happened today we had some
unusual things happen during the
presentation that I
not totally sure why or if they'll ever
happen again but I really appreciate dr.
Caruso and dr. Childers willingness to
use this technology and presentations
were wonderful and I encourage you folks
to i'm going to leave the website up so
if you want to continue to upload some
of the fact sheets about the
presentations and if
if you want to go back and listen to the
archived version that might be helpful
as well these are big issues right now
so I just appreciate hope and then we
have one other question from tom
stevenson about what about vectors to be
concerned about what baby yes
should I answer that I think the same
vectors would be an issue if you're
growing organically or conventionally
maybe there will be less control in the
organic situation I wouldn't be
concerned about vectors unless you had a
virus problem or maybe if your neighbor
had a virus problem I would say that
really in most cases viruses get
transmitted by taking cuttings and I
know we have several growers in Michigan
who have you know said oh yeah i just
kept cuttings from my neighbor and yes
you know that seems to be the problem
because the neighbor also had a virus
problem in some cases some growers have
noticed that people have been taking
cuttings from their planting at night
and anyway I could be a problem if you
have had a virus be a problem for the
thieves and the additional questions for
dr. shoulder or dr. Caruso if not I'm
going to officially end
stop the recording of it but I'll leave
it up here in case you want to continue
to duck the fact sheets i really
appreciate everyone's patience and i
want to draw your attention to the next
webinar which is on December second
again a wednesday at one o'clock and we
will be talking about site preparation
for blueberries and fertility and
pollination myths so thanks but thanks
again very much
Thank You Laura
you
you